um it's kind of crazy too because like
did you see this recent clip of Patrick
Beverly saying less than half of the
league
doesn't or no more than half a league
doesn't enjoy playing basketball they're
just in it for the
money essentially right do you like I
feel like with like your era it wasn't
that way
I don't know like and also do you like
did you see did you see the clip I saw
it I saw it what do you think about that
I think he I mean when you look kind of
look at what's going on you kind of
believe it right for sure I say that is
just because the fact that they take all
these rest days just like you know like
to your point I era bro like every game
meant something right every [__] game
is something right you understand what
I'm saying like our mindsets was like
every game determined playoff seating
all kind of stuff right what kind of
contract you might get like now guys get
paid when they hurt they get guys that
play you know 30 40 of the games over a
three year spending and Superman still
get the super max like shout out to Zion
eating bro yeah big shout out to him and
listen he's a great place when he's
playing he's like the most he might I
think offensive he's the most efficient
player in the NBA when he's healthy I
think two years ago he was the most
efficient Woolen China shot broke hand
Garden oh it's crazy got guys like guys
literally won't play anything he said
people will have like literally you've
been in the league for four years and
you played 30 or 40 of your games and
they match you out like so now to that
point is like how do you love the game
you know what I'm saying like you like
you of your rookie contract you just
made 200 million dollars like what do I
care about the rest of my career you
know what I'm saying it takes special
players that are thinking about Legacy
and thinking about chasing records you
understand what I'm saying that I think
that will show through and those will be
the guys that will like enjoy throughout
the rest of their careers especially as
being like true hoop fans you know what
I'm saying but I definitely agree with
them man I think that these guys are
more enamored with the lifestyle over
the game right like I said like back
I'll just give you one more example like
when I was coming up like you can't get
hurt bro because you had like a guy
behind you that was like ready they just
needed that opportunity so like if I
rolled my ankle but I got like Jonathan
Bender who hasn't played in 10 games but
he killing in practice every day he's
just waiting I gotta play on a bum ankle
bro you know what I'm saying but
remember Jonathan yeah like so it's just
chained now it's like you go out you sit
for two months you come right back your
spot right there no matter what the
person was doing in front of you they're
trained him first over you know what I'm
saying so I I have to agree with him bro
I think he might be right about that
yeah and I think too because like I have
two kids that both like play they love
basketball you know but there's so much
there's something to be said about like
the AAU [__] and then also like
Tick Tock and Instagram making a lot of
these like 16 17 year old kids Super
Famous and Rich and Rich before they
even get to the NBA so they're like when
I watch the draft sometimes and I see
like
dudes I see as [__] like
grabbing their hat I'm like bro like
what's up with all this jewelry like
shout out to scoot Henderson who I heard
is absolute Hooper I heard he's gonna be
amazing I heard he's got a generational
talent I heard he's amazing like and I
heard he's got the right mind state but
he was so iced down the whole family I
was just like
what's the like gee like Bro you've been
making money for two years because he
was he went to the gym overtime thing
but you know once he did that he knew he
was never going to college so now he
could do all kind of deals he had Puma
ads before he even got your you
understand what I'm saying like so to
your point because it is name image and
likeness thing which it really means now
it's legal that's what it really should
stand for you know what I'm saying these
kids are getting access to money and I
mean even like the kid Mikey Williams
right for sure what I've heard he's not
even an NBA Talent that's what I heard I
never seen him play and you know
whatever I think I met him at Africa
when he was like 15. bro he's made
already made like 15 million dollars
[Music]
and you know shout out to him I know
he's dealing with whatever he's dealing
with but you see something like that and
you're like
the internet is the component that might
have [__] this kid's career up yeah
that like too much Fame too early too
much Fame too early and that's what you
know and obviously that's what all of
this [__] is that's what media does
right it builds you up to tear you down
you know what I'm saying so
um even that perspective of just like
you know Tick Tock Instagram like it's
making kids famous that aren't even that
good it's just it's that's what you know
what I really enjoyed was I just watched
uh all the smokes podcast this morning I
threw on they had a episode Austin
Reeves drop and to see like his
perspective he purposely didn't want to
get drafted
he said that the Detroit Pistons wanted
to draft him at 42. right but him and
his team had a tier of teams that he
could fit in right and he said well once
we fall past this number in the second
round it's going to be a two-way
contract no matter what right so when
they wanted to draft him his agent
called him and said we're okay we have a
plan we want to go undrafted so he
decided he bet on himself right because
he knew the Lakers had interest and he
said there was two teams that they had
as the one tier that he could fit in and
like really Thrive and it was the Bucks
and the Lakers so he really liked bet on
himself and like but that's smart I mean
second round picks a lot of times that
it's too I don't fully understand the
two-way contract thing because I wasn't
in when that was right right
but when I was in a second round pick
you only got one you would never really
none of these were guaranteed but it's
really like there's no guarantee it was
really like two years my era it was
really like a two-year guarantee but you
think about it if you got a two-year
guarantee I was a first round pick I had
four years guarantee so it took me two
more years before I could get to some
money right so if you're good in your
first the first year or two you were
beat out the guy that was the first
round pick you know what I'm saying
because you'll get you'll get to a
contract faster if you bet on yourself
to your point sometimes like when you
see certain guys because I look I looked
at like uh because I've been watching a
lot of your older interviews and stuff
and
um obviously watched you play I always
thought you were like I would say like
you were like one of those guys who like
would play the Suns or play like a like
a team and you just like be on Sports
and be like yo [__] now Harrington
like 42 tonight like you were you you
had like [__] you were a bucket
getter bro and uh
the pay structure now oh my god when you
see like I think of a guy like Jeremy
Grant and the deal he just got and
Jeremy Grant's a good NBA player but you
know he's not an All-Star you know but I
think of Jeremy Grant I'm like I think
he signed for a buck 80. maybe a buck 60
something like that God bless him God
bless him shout out to you get that
money but I'm like yo you're the kind of
guy who in 2023 could have got like a
buck 80. oh my God hands down bro like
to see your point like God just
averaging 12 13 points what's happening
it's insane they gotta spend the money
is the TV or all the TV all the media
stuff was like taking off crazy uh you
see like I think uh Tatum will be the
first guy that's gonna get I think oh my
God Jalen Brown it's brown he about to
get 70 million a year it's Jaylen Brown
yeah I think it's 70 million a year
that's crazy you know what I'm saying so
even like when Dame signed that deal and
they were like I was like wait the fifth
year 60 what the [__]
so now like to your point like now just
being like the 10th best player on your
team bro you and you guaranteed 10 to 15
million dollars you know what I'm saying
so the game has changed a lot now I
gotta I gotta pour everything I got into
my son since I got two little boys 75.
like hey guys I hope we get some of that
money
if one of you two make it we're chilling
we're chilling